Well, welcome. This is, this is a very, very special nerve-wracking, odd, unique, incredible episode. This is amazing. And why? Let's just stay at the top. Why? And then I want to get in. Well, they know, because by this point, they know that the President of the United States is approaching the ring. Okay. So talk to me about coming here and getting here, because I got here an hour earlier because I thought it was going to be massive traffic and blah, blah, blah. And so, and it's,
欢迎收听。这是一集非常、非常特别，让人神经紧绷，既怪异、独特又不可思议的节目。这太棒了。为什么呢？我们就开门见山地说。为什么？然后我想深入聊聊。好吧，他们懂，因为这时候他们知道美国总统正朝着这辆车走来。好吧。所以跟我聊聊来到这里并进入这里的过程，因为我提前一个小时就到了，因为我觉得会有巨大的交通堵塞等等，然后呢，
the steps you take to get through with your car was mind-blowing. Well, you also had some flares on your record. You had to get here now. Yeah, you did have a few outstandings. A bunch of questions for you. Right, right. You had a few things. Will and I just got to roll up, get the mirrors underneath the car and that's it. Yeah.
你开车通过安检的那些步骤简直让人大开眼界。好吧，你的记录上也有一些违规记录。你现在必须得来这儿。是的，你确实有几个未决的问题。一堆问题要问你。对，对。你有几桩事。威利和我直接把车开过去，把镜子伸到车底下检查，然后就完了。对。
I had the dog sniffing all parts of me. Oh, no, I know. But wait, so no, but the guy, by the way, one of the guys doing, this is true, doing the check on the security check on the car. He says to Jason like, Hey man, big fan. And then he sort of leaned in and then he was just out of your shot. Jason looks at me and goes, nothing for you. Nothing for you.
我经历了被警犬从头到脚到处闻。哦，不，我知道。但是等等，所以，顺便说一句，其中一个做这件事的人——这是真的，对车进行安全检查的人。他对杰森说：嘿，哥们，我是你的超级粉丝。然后他有点凑近身子，接着他就退出了你的镜头。杰森看着我说：没你的份。没你的份。
He actually leaned down and look who was riding shotgun and then just kept walking. No, he didn't. But he said, nothing. Jason goes, nothing for you. And then the guy walked back and I thought, oh, he's placed the face. He's going to come back and the guy said, and just keep your windows rolled down and going forward. Yeah. And it was, and it was, it was a great moment.
他真的俯下身子，看看是谁坐在副驾驶座上，然后就直接走开了。不，他没这么做。但他说，没你的份。杰森说，没你的份。然后那个人走回去了，我想，哦，他认出这张脸了。他要回来了，结果那家伙说，把车窗摇下来，继续往前开。对，而且，这是一个很棒的时刻。
It was a great moment. And then, and then the next guy said, he said to me, he was a big fan of murder. They didn't say murderville. He said, of your improv. And then he said, oh, and then he looked at it. So Jason goes, I love Ozark. And to which I said, is that still on the air? Because it's been a minute.
这是一个美妙的时刻。然后，然后接下来那个人说，他对我说，他是《谋杀维尔》的超级粉丝。他们没说《谋杀维尔》。他说，是你即兴表演的粉丝。然后他说，哦，接着他看了看。所以杰森说：我喜欢《黑钱胜地》。对此我回答说：那部剧还在播吗？因为已经过去好一会儿了。
And then we approached the woman with the bullhorn out there yelling, yelling protests. And she gave me an earful. So we're at a hotel in Los Angeles because Well, let's definitely be cagey about it because they're going to come after us now. After we've already done it. Two weeks after. But I mean, just for the future, we should. For the future.
接着我们走近了外面那个拿着大喇叭大喊大叫、抗议的女人。她把我训斥了一顿。所以我们现在在洛杉矶的一家酒店里，因为……好吧，我们对具体地点绝对要守口如瓶，因为他们现在要来找我们麻烦了。在我们已经录完之后。两周之后。但我的意思是，为了以后着想，我们应该保密。为了以后。
It might be a hotspot then. You think that people can't clue into the fact that the president's here? What gave it away? The beast out parked in the middle of Hill Guard? What are you doing? 75 trucks outside. Did you guys just come fresh from, were you just lobotomized from Dunland? You're so nervous.
那到时候它可能就会变成一个热点地区了。你觉得人们不会发现总统在这里吗？是什么暴露了目标？停在希尔加德中间的那辆“野兽”座驾？你在干什么？外面停了75辆卡车。你们俩刚从哪儿来？你们刚从邓兰做过脑白金切除手术吗？你们太紧张了。
Rise to the moment. I'm up. I'm up. I'm in. I'm in. Well, this is exciting. The president of the United States is our guest today, which is absolute. Let's do a small little humble review on what the hell is going on. I mean, when you're a kid and you watch TV and you see, oh my God, there's the president. And then you learn about history and like, oh my God, I fast forward to this moment right now. It's kind of mind blowing and I'm very nervous.
把握住这个时刻。我准备好了。我准备好了。我加入了。我加入了。好吧，这太令人兴奋了。美国总统今天做客我们的节目，这绝对是……让我们对到底是怎么回事做一个简短的小结。我的意思是，当你还是个孩子的时候，你看电视，看到，哦天哪，那是总统。然后你了解了历史，就像，哦天哪，快进到眼下的这一刻。这简直太震撼了，我非常紧张。
I was feeling really, really good about us. And then, and then I saw he did an exclusive with Tapper yesterday. And I'm like, well, fucking Tapper got him. I mean, maybe this isn't that big of a deal. Well, Tapper is a bit of a heat seeking missile, isn't he? Maybe this isn't as big of a deal. It's kind of huge. No, old Tapper shoes deserves it.
我本来对我们俩感觉非常好、非常不错。然后，然后我看到他昨天接受了塔珀的独家采访，我想，好吧，他妈的塔珀采访到他了。我的意思是，也许这也没什么大不了的。好吧，塔珀有点像枚热寻导弹，不是吗？也许这并没有那么重要。这简直太重大了。不，老塔珀凭实力配得上。
Yeah, but we do. I mean, he's a friend of the show, but Tapper. But this is undoubtedly, this is ridiculous. We have the president. Can I tell you this? I told my dad that we were doing this. Me too. And how'd you do that? What'd you do? Put a message in the bottle and throw it in Lake Michigan?
对，但我们也是。我的意思是，他是节目的朋友，但塔珀……但毫无疑问，这太荒谬了。我们请到了总统。我能告诉你这个吗？我跟我爸说我们要录这个。我也是。你是怎么说的？你是怎么做的？把信塞进瓶子里扔进密歇根湖？
Hoping he drives his powerboat by it? Hoping that one of his kids from his new family picks it up. Yeah, it's pretty ridiculous. My dad was so impressed and he was so blown away. There's very few things. And you know, you get to do a lot of cool things in what we do. And my dad was like, when I said, yeah, we're interviewing the president, he said, really? Like in this way of like, you?
希望他开着动力艇路过？希望他新家庭里的某个孩子能捡到？是的，这太荒谬了。我爸印象太深刻了，他简直惊呆了。没几件事能这样。你知道的，在我们的行业里，你能做很多酷炫的事。当我跟我爸说，对，我们要采访总统时，他说，真的吗？那种语气就像是在说：就你？
Yeah. Like I got to start listening to this. Yeah, and I get it. And it is. I mean, who is this? First of all, for you guys, all jokes aside, I wasn't born in this country, but I can appreciate it. But as young as Americans who have come, this has got to be a great moment for you. Well, this is unbelievable.
对。就像我得开始听这档节目了。对，我懂。确实如此。我的意思是，这是谁？首先，对你们来说，抛开玩笑不谈，我不是在这个国家出生的，但我能欣赏它。但作为年轻的美国人，经历这一切，对你们来说这一定是个伟大的时刻。哦，这太难以置信了。
Because it is for me. And I'm a new American. But just aside from this podcast, it's like, I get to meet the president of the United States. Like it's insane. I mean, it's so crazy. We started this thing as just a completely, you know, remote kind of situation where we stayed in contact. And now we are. And try to make Sean feel better because he was so depressed.
因为对我来说也是如此。而且我是个新美国人。但抛开这个播客不谈，这就像，我能见到美国总统。这太疯狂了。我的意思是，这太疯狂了。我们开始做这件事时，完全是一个，你知道的，远程的情况，我们靠保持联系。而现在我们……并且尽量让肖恩感觉好点，因为他太沮丧了。
Exactly. Still working on it. But now we are for the first time in person. And we're not in our pajamas. We're in nice clothes. And there's all this stuff that needs to be returned by noon tomorrow. And Jason asked me if I'd tuck the tags in. But for good reason.
没错。还在努力调整。但现在我们第一次面对面了。而且我们没有穿睡衣。我们穿得很体面。所有这些衣服都得在明天中午前归还。杰森还问我有没有把吊牌塞进去。但这是有充分理由的。
Yeah. Little babies grew up. Yeah. Well, guys, tighten up, tighten up. I think I see some people coming in. All right, listener, listener. Next time we talk to you, we're going to be in the midst. It's still us, but we are going to be acting a little weird because obviously.
对。小宝贝们长大了。对。好吧，各位，打起精神，打起精神。我想我看到有人进来了。好了，听众朋友们，听众朋友们。我们下一次和你们对话时，我们将身处其中。依然是我们，但我们会表现得有点奇怪，因为很明显……
Right? It's weirder than right now. Yeah. Can you feel the nervous energy, listener? I'm actually really honestly truly nervous. Yeah, no me too. All right, here we go. All right, let's tighten up
对吧？比现在还要奇怪。对。听众朋友们，你们能感受到那种紧张的能量吗？我其实真的很诚实、很真心地感到紧张。对，不，我也是。好吧，我们开始吧。好吧，让我们打起精神……
and we'll talk to you in a second when... We come back on an all new, very special... Smart... Less. Smart. Less. Smart. Less.
我们一会儿再和你们聊，当……我们在一档全新的、非常特别的节目中回归……聪明……无知。聪明。无知。聪明。无知。
Smart. Less. You're making me famous with my granddaughter, guys. I got... This is wild. This is unbelievable for all of us. So thank you for being here. It's such an honor.
聪明。无知。伙计们，你们让我在我孙女面前出名了。我有……这太疯狂了。这对我们所有人来说都难以置信。所以谢谢你们来到这里。这真是个巨大的荣幸。
Thank you. No, no, it's an honor to be on. I mean, what you guys did to lift people's spirits is important. Well, thanks. It's been a tough time. And we're surprised that just our silly little chit chats are making people grin,
谢谢你们。不，不，能上节目是我的荣幸。我的意思是，你们为振奋人心所做的事很重要。好吧，谢谢。这段时间很艰难。我们很惊讶，仅仅是我们这些无聊的小闲聊就能让人会心一笑，
but I guess we'll just, we'll keep at it because a smile is always worth it especially nowadays. And we often have a lot of... We started by getting a lot of our friends on here and people who are performers and people who are... And so Sean won't be able to ask his normal question. Do you have any great theater stories? I got a lot of great theater.
但我想我们会坚持下去，因为微笑永远是值得的，尤其是在当今时代。而且我们经常有很多……我们一开始邀请了很多朋友上节目，有表演者，还有……所以肖恩不能问他通常会问的问题了。你有什么精彩的戏剧故事吗？我有很多精彩的戏剧故事。
Right? Well, I know Trump. That's the best theater ever. Hey, you know, before we start, I don't have a question. I just wanna say a thank you for something. And I have to read a quote that you said almost 10 years ago. And now that you're sitting in front of me
对吧？好吧，我认识特朗普。那是有史以来最棒的戏剧。嘿，你知道，在我们开始之前，我没有问题。我只想为一件事表示感谢。我得朗读一段你将近10年前说过的话。现在你坐在我面前，
and it's such an honor and I'm shaking a little bit, but you said... A lot of that's the sugar. A lot of that's the sugar earlier. I, you said, I think Will and Grace did more to educate the American public more than almost anything anybody has done so far and as much as relating... Well, by the way, you did.
这真是一个莫大的荣幸，我甚至有点发抖，但你说过……这很大程度上是因为糖分。这很大程度上是因为刚才摄入的糖分。你，你说过，我认为《威尔和格蕾丝》在教育美国公众方面所做的工作，比迄今为止几乎任何人所做的都要多，并且在建立……好吧，顺便说一句，你确实做到了。
To tell you, thank you. And I was sitting on the couch and nearly fell out of my seat. And it just meant so much to me and a million other people, millions of other people that you recognized us and spoke up for us. So thank you. No question.
我想对你说谢谢。当时我正坐在沙发上，差一点从座位上摔下来。这对我和其他几百万、数百万其他人来说意义重大，因为你们认可了我们并为我们发声。所以谢谢你们。没有问题。
I just wanted to say thank you. No, no, I didn't think it was a quote, but look, I, but it's the truth. You know, people are afraid where they don't know. Yeah. And they're frightened of it. And they had images that every gay person in the world or lesbian was an extremist on everything.
我只是想说谢谢。不，不，我没想到那是一句名言，但听着，我，但这是事实。你知道的，人们对不了解的事物感到恐惧。是的。而且他们对此感到害怕。他们脑海中的形象是，世界上所有的同性恋者或女同性恋者在所有事情上都是极端分子。
Right. But it's like... We're just as boring as everybody else. That's true, by the way. Look at this stuff up card again there, look at that. Far more, often far more boring. No, no, but think about it. The first, you made it clear that gay person's interest
对。但事实是……我们跟其他人一样无聊。顺便说一句，这是真的。看这小卡片，瞧瞧这个。往往更无聊，通常得多。不，不，但想想看。首先，你明确指出同性恋者的兴趣
and life is not any fundamentally different. I mean, they have the same fears, concerns, ambitions, likes, I mean, it's normal. Yeah. And thank you for giving us the same rights as everybody else. Speaking of Sean, you clearly stated your love for Will and Grace.
和生活并没有什么根本的不同。我的意思是，他们有同样的恐惧、担忧、雄心、喜好，我的意思是，这很正常。是的。谢谢你给了我们和其他人一样的权利。说到肖恩，你明确表达了你对《威尔和格蕾丝》的喜爱。
Now that makes me think, what other television shows are you able to watch now that you've got a fairly busy job? Is there any TV time for you? Well, the honest to God truth is, it's a joke among my granddaughters who, very little. When I have time on television, what I tend to do is I tend to watch sports or watch the news. And by the way, I don't work harder
这让我想到，既然你有一份相当忙碌的工作，你现在还能看什么其他的电视节目？你有什么看电视的时间吗？好吧，上帝见证的实话实数是，在我的孙女们中间这是一个笑话，（我看电视的时间）非常少。当我有时间看电视时，我往往会看体育节目或看新闻。顺便说一句，我工作并不比……
and a lot of people work a hell of a lot harder than I do. I don't know about that. But there's just not that many hours. You know what I mean? But I want to look, because we're not bright enough to ask you really smart questions. I'm really, I'm such a big fan of you as just, obviously we've never met before,
许多人比我刻苦得多。我可不这么认为。但实在没有那么多小时。你知道我的意思吗？但我想要，看吧，因为我们不够聪明，问不出你真正聪明的问题。我真的很，我是你的超级粉丝，单纯作为……显然我们以前从未见过面，
although I did shake your hand on a school trip in ninth grade in Delaware and you were very nice. But I want to know, I want to know. Have you been since? You've been so sweet for our class. But like, what time does the day wrap up for you? What, you go upstairs. You want to go bed time.
虽然我在九年级去特拉华州学校旅行时跟你握过手，当时你人非常好。但我想知道，我想知道。你从那以后去过吗？你对我们班太好了。但是，你一般几点结束一天的工作？什么，你上楼去。你想睡觉的时间。
Well, I want to know what goes on. My staff is laughing, they're behind it. But when you go upstairs, you're not lounging around in that. Is there a transition into, I'm asking because I'm projecting, because I get in my PJs as soon as I get home. You get into the PJs, you let them know what you want for dinner and then you start watching TV with Jill?
好吧，我想知道发生了什么。我的工作人员在笑，他们在后面。但当你上楼时，你不会穿着那身衣服闲逛吧。是不是有一个过渡，切换到……我这么问是因为我在投射，因为我一回家就换上睡衣。你换上睡衣，让他们知道你想吃什么晚餐，然后开始和吉尔一起看电视？
Is that, what happens? That's one of the things Jill and I are working out. And I mean this sincerely. Jill, because she teaches full time, is in bed by 9.30 and I used to go to bed 9.30, 10 o'clock and we talk and people go to sleep. I mean, we spend time together. But now I don't get back to my, even in the White House,
是这样吗，发生了什么？这是吉尔和我正在努力调整的事情之一。我是真心这么说的。吉尔因为要全职教书，所以在九点半就上床睡觉了，而我过去常常九点半、十点钟睡觉，我们会聊天，然后大家入睡。我的意思是，我们花时间在一起。但现在我回不到，即使在白宫里，
I don't get from the Oval Office into my, in the residence, until usually around seven o'clock. We have dinner and then I have, and I'm not a complaint. I give my word, but I have a briefing book that is probably 200 pages. I mean, a big binder like that. Mine has two pages and they're all noodles. No, but the worst part,
我也常常直到七点左右才从椭圆形办公室回到起居室。我们吃晚饭，然后我还有——我不是在抱怨。我向你保证，但我有一本简报册，大概有200页。我的意思是，有那么大一本活页夹。我的只有两页，上面全画着面条。不，但最糟糕的是，
you guys got to memorize your lines. But all kidding aside, so I usually get in bed around 11 o'clock. Jill gets up at 6.30 and it goes, works out. I get up at 8 o'clock and work out. But wait, I want to know, I want to know though, when you, is there a time that, when you exercising with Jill,
你们还得背台词。但抛开玩笑不谈，所以我通常在11点左右上床睡觉。吉尔6点30分起床，然后去健身。我8点起床去健身。等等，我想知道，我想知道的是，当你和吉尔一起锻炼时，
is there a time where you guys can go away and shut it off and just be like, yeah? Well, we just have to do it because she'd worked so long as well, so we just set time and I tell Annie who runs the show for me and my chief of staff, I'm not doing anything. And so Jill and I, they're getting further apart. I mean, in a sense, but usually we try to do that.
有没有一段时间你们可以走开，把一切关掉，就只是……你知道的？好吧，我们只能这么做，因为她也工作了很长时间，所以我们只是设定好时间，我告诉帮我管理日程的安妮和我的幕僚长，我什么都不做。所以吉尔和我……他们的距离越来越远了。我的意思是，某种意义上，但通常我们尽量这样做。
We go to Camp David or go back to our house in Delaware, which is secluded enough off the road, that we just, you know. And can you really not think about work and you really kind of calm down? Is it always there? Yeah, no, well, there's certain things that, I mean, like with the war in Ukraine,
我们会去戴维营，或者回到我们在特拉华州的家，那里离路边足够偏僻，我们可以……你知道的。而且你们真的能不想工作、真正放松下来吗？工作总是挥之不去吗？是的，不，好吧，有些事情，我的意思是，比如乌克兰战争，
there's a lot of really difficult to, so sure. But no, I'm always available. But they try to protect you, obviously weekends are not off, but you get to go to church on Sundays or you get to do a little sports to your mom. My worst part is they kid me and everybody kids me. I'm one of those practicing Catholics.
有很多非常难以处理的事情，所以当然。但是，不，我随时待命。但他们会试着保护你，显然周末也不能完全休息，但你星期天可以去教堂，或者你可以陪妈妈做点体育活动。最糟糕的是，他们开我玩笑，所有人都开我玩笑。我是那种虔诚的天主教徒。
My mother come down from heaven if I didn't. But I go to, I go to, I don't tell everybody because they'll beat it, but I go to five o'clock mass in my local church. Or I go to, in Washington, I go over to Georgetown, the Jebys. And I go to, there's a five, well, there's a 430 mass. And I go to mass on Saturday.
如果我不去，我妈会从天国下来找我的。但我去，我去——我不会告诉所有人，因为他们会纠缠不休，但我去我当地教堂的五点弥撒。或者我去，在华盛顿，我去乔治敦的耶稣会教堂。我去，有一场五点——好吧，有一场四点半的弥撒。我周六去参加弥撒。
And then Sunday, we just try to do nothing. Yeah, yeah. That's great. I mean, that's pretty good. I think you have to. Football game or something like that. Yeah. Yeah.
然后周日，我们尽量什么都不做。对，对。太棒了。我的意思是，这挺不错的。我想你必须得这样。看场橄榄球比赛什么的。对。对。
What's your number one sport if you had to rank them that you like to watch? My number one sport is football, but it's changed so much. I was a relatively good ball player in a high school. I was a flanker back, a half back. Really? And I like flank state. And yeah.
如果你必须按喜好给它们排个名，你最喜欢的运动是什么？我最喜欢的运动是橄榄球，但它现在的变化太大了。我上高中时是个相当不错的球员。我是个翼卫，半卫。真的吗？我喜欢Flank州。对，没错。
I'm just saying. Don't pay any attention. You're just saying word association. Yeah, just saying word association. It's a sport that I watch probably more than any other. Don't catch up. You're not a terrible golfer. I looked up your index.
我只是随口说说。别在意。你只是在玩词语联想。对，只是词语联想。这是我看得最多的运动，可能超过其他任何运动。别上当。你的高尔夫水平可不赖。我查过你的差点指数。
I used to be pretty good. I haven't played golf on three. Your current index is a six, seven, I believe, which puts you at about a 12 handicap. What is the best part of your golf game? Off the tee, chipping, putting? Off the tee. Off the tee.
我过去挺厉害的。我已经有三个……你目前的差点指数是六点七，我相信这相当于大约12的差点。你高尔夫球技最好的是哪一部分？开球、切击、推杆？开球。开球。
Of course it is. Do you hit it far? Well, yeah, three years ago I did. I haven't played much. Yeah, I love it. We added up, they figured out that I try to, when I'm home in Delaware, there's a place I can go where I can play, it's a private club, it's called Fieldstone,
当然是。你打得很远吗？好吧，是的，三年前是的。我没怎么打过。对，我喜欢。我们算了一下，他们发现，当我回到特拉华州的家时，有一个地方我可以去打球，那是个私人俱乐部，叫菲尔德斯通，
but I play all of this golf and I get in, I've not played 18 holes lately, nine holes. I'm with you on that. We play a lot. Jason and I play a lot of golf. Will's big thing is he thinks golf should be 12 holes. I think it should be 12 holes. I think it should be six and six.
但我打的所有这些高尔夫，最近我没有打满18洞，只打9洞。在这点上我和你一样。我们经常打。杰森和我经常打高尔夫。威利最大的观点是他认为高尔夫应该只有12洞。我认为应该打12洞。我认为应该是前六洞和后六洞。
I think that would be perfect. By the way, there's a lot of national debate about that. Is there really? Yeah, there is about. Do you want to appoint me the golf star? Is this something that's- Because he falls apart at 12, usually. He falls apart on the 12th ball and he just starts whining.
我觉得那样最完美。顺对此，全国上下有很多关于这方面的争论。真的吗？对，关于……你想任命我为高尔夫特使吗？这是某种……因为他在第12洞就会崩溃，通常是这样。他在第12洞就会发挥失常，然后就开始发牢骚。
And I'm tired. And I like to spend time with my kids. You need to work on your game. By the way, that's my best recreation. My granddaughters. They're crazy about me. Ah, crazy about me. No, you think I'm kidding.
而且我累了。我喜欢花时间陪我的孩子们。你需要提高你的球技。顺便说一句，这是我最好的休闲活动。我的孙女们。她们迷死我了。啊，迷死我了。不，你以为我在开玩笑。
I don't blame them. I don't love that. Every single day I contact every one of my grandchildren. That's amazing. You got to pick one of these three things as the coolest thing about being the man. Is it the White House? Is it Air Force One or is it the Beast?
我才不怪她们。我怎么会不爱呢。我每天都会联系我的每一个孙辈。这太了不起了。你得从这三样东西里选出一个作为当总统最酷的事。是白宫？是空军一号，还是“野兽”座驾？
Which, you can only, you can only- You don't mean Marshawn Lynch. I do not. I'm talking about the car. Okay. Which, which is the, which, which- Air Force One. It's the Air Force One.
你只能，你只能……你不是指肖恩·林奇吧？我不是。我说的是那辆车。好吧。空军一号是哪个，哪个，哪个……空军一号。非空军一号莫属。
It's got to be Air Force One. Yeah, it's got to be, right? Well, the good news is a plane never leaves when I get there. No, no, no. Yes, yes. Do you always get the seat you want? Do you always get the seat you want
肯定得是空军一号。对，肯定是的，对吧？好吧，好消息是，当我到达时，飞机绝不会不等我起飞。不，不，不。是的，是的。你总能坐到你想坐的座位吗？你总是能坐到你想坐的座位吗，
or is there sometimes there's someone in it? And you got to go to the back. I would love to see the inside of Air Force One. Sean, I'll take you through it. I would guys, I would go crazy. I was so dripping with begging for an invite. No, I'm- No, I'm serious.
还是有时上面已经有人了？然后你得去后面。我很想看看空军一号的内部。肖恩，我带你参观。伙计们，我会疯狂的。我当时简直渴望能求到一个邀请。不，我——不，我是认真的。
I'm serious. Sean, you're only, you're only, I thought you were gonna say, I'd love to do a Will and Grace reunion on Air Force One. And we will be right back. SmartLiz is sponsored by BetterHelp. Okay. So life is complicated.
我是认真的。肖恩，你只——我还以为你会说，我很想在空军一号上搞一次《威尔和格蕾丝》重聚呢。我们马上回来。《SmartLess》由BetterHelp赞助。好了。所以生活很复杂。
That's our baseline. And it's taken me a number of years to accept that. Acceptance is a huge, huge thing for me. Letting go of control, another huge thing for me. And there have been a lot of times in my life where I've had a tough time accepting stuff. I've had a tough time letting go and realizing that I'm not in control.
这是我们的基准。我花了好多年的时间才接受这一点。对我来说，接受是一个非常、非常巨大的改变。放手掌控，对我的另一个重大改变。在我生命中有很多次，我对接受现实感到非常困难。我对放手感到困难，并意识到我无法掌控一切。
And so we learn as we go. And we learn as we go by, for me, my experience by talking to people about what's going on. It's normal to feel stuck. And therapists are trained to help you figure out the cause of challenging emotions and learn productive coping skills. Huge.
所以我们在边走边学。对我而言，我们的学习经验是通过与他人谈论正在发生的事情来获得的。感到卡住是正常的。治疗师受过专业训练，能帮你找出具有挑战性的情绪的根源，并学习富有成效的应对技巧。这太重要了。
Which makes therapy the closest thing to a guided tour, if you will, of the complex engine called you. As the world's largest therapy service, BetterHelp has matched 3 million people with professionally licensed and vetted therapists available 100% online. Plus, it's affordable. So you just fill out a brief questionnaire
这使得心理治疗最接近于一次“导游导览”——如果你愿意这么说的话——带你了解名为“你”的复杂引擎。作为全球最大的心理治疗服务机构，BetterHelp已经将300万人与拥有专业执照并经过严格背景调查的治疗师进行了匹配，这些服务100%在线提供。此外，它价格实惠。所以你只需填写一份简短的问卷，
to match with a therapist. And if things aren't clicking, you can easily switch to a new therapist anytime. It could not be simpler. No waiting rooms, no traffic, no endless searching for the right therapist. Learn more and save 10% off your first month at betterhelp.com slash smartless.
就能与治疗师匹配。如果感觉不对头，你可以随时轻松更换新治疗师。再简单不过了。没有候诊室，没有交通堵塞，无需无休止地寻找合适的治疗师。访问betterhelp.com/smartless了解更多信息并节省首月10%的费用。
That's better help. H-E-L-P.com slash smartless. We wanna thank Aura for supporting the show. How many devices do you think you have at home that are connected to the internet? You got your phones and your computers and your doorbells and your cameras and your things. The average is 25 devices per household
网址是betterhelp.com/smartless。我们想感谢Aura对节目的支持。你觉得家里有多少设备是连接到互联网的？你有手机、电脑、门铃、摄像头和各种东西。每个家庭平均有25台设备，
and 100 online accounts per person. Guess what, Kang, that's a lot. We do everything online from banking to binge watching to homework with our kids. And this has left us extremely vulnerable. In fact, last year, Americans lost $6.9 billion to online crime and this number is only rising. And the risk isn't just for your wallet.
每人拥有100个在线账户。你猜怎么着，哥们，这可真不少。我们在网上做所有事情，从银行业务、疯狂刷剧到帮孩子做家庭作业。这让我们变得极其脆弱。事实上，去年美国人在网络犯罪中损失了69亿美元，而且这个数字还在不断上升。风险不仅限于你的钱包。
Last year, 1.25 million kids had their identity stolen. That's one in every 45 kids. Many don't even know they've been a victim until they're older and applying for a school loan or a first apartment. Listen, as a parent, it's so, when I first found out about what we were gonna do here with Aura, I was really excited
去年有125万儿童的身份信息被盗。平均每45个孩子中就有一个。许多人直到年龄稍大、申请助学贷款或第一套公寓时，才知道自己曾是受害者。听着，作为一个父母，当我第一次了解到我们要在这里和Aura合作时，我真的非常兴奋，
because I can know that my family, specifically my kids are safe when they're online because let's be honest, they're spending a lot of time online. I don't know, it feels like sometimes with the internet that the possibilities are infinite in good ways and potentially in bad ways. So I wanna know that I can protect my family,
因为我可以知道我的家人，特别是我的孩子在上网时是安全的，因为说实话，他们花了很多很多时间在网上。我不知道，有时感觉互联网既有无限的好可能，也有潜在的坏可能。所以我希望知道我能尽我所能保护我的家人、我的孩子，而Aura正在帮助我们做到这一点。
my kids as well as I can and Aura is helping us do that. Also, with Aura, the price you pay when you sign up is the price you pay when you renew. They will not raise your prices in year two, hoping that you won't notice. Now, for a limited time, Aura is offering our listener a 14-day trial and a scan of your information to see if you've been part of a data breach,
此外，使用Aura时，你注册时支付的价格就是你续费时的价格。他们不会在第二年悄悄涨价，指望你不会注意到。现在，在限时优惠期间，Aura为我们的听众提供14天免费试用，并对你的信息进行扫描，看看你是否曾遭遇数据泄露，
all for free when you visit aura.com slash smartlist. So just go to aura.com slash smartlist and sign up for a 14-day free trial to see if you've already been part of a data breach. That's A-U-R-A.com slash smartlist. Certain terms apply, C-site for details. Aura, the new standard in online safety. Smartlist is brought to you in part by Audible.
访问aura.com/smartless即可全部免费获得。所以只需访问aura.com/smartless并注册14天免费试用，看看你是否已经成为数据泄露的受害者。网址是Aura.com/smartless。某些条款适用，请访问网站了解详情。Aura，网络安全的新标准。《SmartLess》部分内容由Audible呈献。
You don't ride an elevator for the music or pick an airline for the movies. So when it comes to audio entertainment, it makes sense to choose Audible. It's the home for stories told by the biggest stars like Ethan Hawke, Carrie Washington, and Kevin Hart. It's home to epic adventures, chilling mysteries, and can't miss comedies.
你不会为了听音乐而去坐电梯，也不会为了看电影去挑选航空公司。所以在音频娱乐方面，选择Audible是理所当然的。这里汇集了由埃文·霍克、凯丽·华盛顿和凯文·哈特等大牌明星讲述的故事。这里是史诗冒险、惊悚悬疑和不容错过的喜剧的聚集地。
Audible is the home of storytelling. Let your imagination soar with audiobooks, podcasts, and originals. You know what I love about Audible? No matter where I am, my imagination can run wild with the lives of celebrities or the journey to my best self or the spider web of true crimes, you know that kind of stuff.
Audible是讲故事的发源地。通过有声书、播客和原创作品让你的想象力尽情驰骋。你知道我最喜欢Audible的什么吗？无论我在哪里，我的想象力都可以随心所欲地驰骋：体验名人的生活、走向更好的自我之旅，或是真实犯罪的蛛丝马迹，你知道那种类型的。
Audible is the home of storytelling with the most incredible selection of audiobooks and podcasts across every genre. You can also find exclusive Audible originals from top celebrities, Hollywood storytellers, and renowned thought leaders. As an Audible member, you can choose one title a month to keep from their entire catalog,
Audible是讲故事的发源地，拥有横跨所有流派的最令人惊叹的有声书和播客精选。你还可以找到来自顶级名流、好莱坞故事讲述者和知名思想领袖的独家Audible原创作品。作为Audible会员，你可以从其整个目录中每月挑选一本作品永久保留，
including the latest bestsellers and new releases. Plus all Audible members can access a wide selection of audiobooks and Audible originals that are included with membership. You know what I'm listening to now? I'm listening to The Gray Man. It's the, there's a movie that's out right now, but it's the book that the movie's based on
包括最新的畅销书和新发布的作品。此外，所有Audible会员都可以访问随会员资格附带的各种有声书和Audible原创作品。你知道我现在在听什么吗？我在听《灰人》。那是，现在有一部上映的电影，但这是电影所根据的原著小说，
and it's by Mark Greeney. And it's got, it's like, you know, it's like a thriller. It's like CAA, it's got life or death. And that, you know, it's kind of like a, it's one of those like mystery thriller kind of, you know, action packed things. You love it, I promise. I love it, I can't wait to see the movie.
作者是马克·格里尼。它包含了，就像，你知道的，它就像一部惊悚片。就像中情局的故事，充满了生死抉择。而且，你知道的，这是一种，它是一种那种神秘惊悚、充满动作场面的东西。你会喜欢的，我向你保证。我很喜欢，我迫不及待想看这部电影了。
I haven't seen the movie. I want to listen to the book first and then see the movie. So let Audible help you discover new ways to laugh, be inspired or be entertained. New members can try it for free for 30 days. Visit audible.com slash smartless or text smartless to 500-500. That's audible.com slash smartless
我还没看过电影。我想先听书，然后再看电影。所以让Audible帮你发现欢笑、灵感或娱乐的新方式。新会员可以免费试用30天。访问audible.com/smartless或发送短信smartless至500-500。网址是audible.com/smartless
or text smartless to 500-500 to try Audible free for 30 days. Audible.com slash smartless. All right, back to the show. Okay, so people in this country never before has it felt like, and I look back, you know, I spent a little bit of time looking back over the way that people spoke and politicians spoke
或发送短信smartless至500-500即可免费试用Audible 30天。Audible.com/smartless。好的，回到节目中。好吧，在这个国家的人们，从来没有像现在这样让人感觉……我回过头去，你知道的，我花了一点时间回顾人们说话的方式和政客说话的方式，
and et cetera, especially in the 20th century. And a lot of the same verbiage was used to scare people, to make, put people, to divide people. And it was, and people say, well, no, this is new. Historically, that has been something. But never before has it seemed like common ground was so far off in the distance. And I'm trying to understand why,
等等，尤其是在20世纪。许多相同的言辞曾被用来吓唬人、把人分化、分裂人群。而且，人们会说，不，这是新鲜事。从历史上看，这一直存在。但从来没有像现在这样，让人觉得共同的立场遥不可及。我正试图理解其中的原因，
because we all share, I had an experience recently where I spent some time with somebody and I didn't find out till later that their perspective on the world was very different from mine. But when he and I were speaking and hanging out one-on-one, we got along very fine. And I thought, wow, isn't that funny?
因为我们所有人都有共鸣。我最近有过一次经历，我跟某人相处了一段时间，直到后来我才发现他对世界的看法与我截然不同。但当我和他单独交谈和相处时，我们相处得非常融洽。我想，哇，这难道不有趣吗？
If I didn't know anything about his politics, he and I got along great. What is it we can do to try to get that back? Because I think that that's something you talk about a lot. Well, I do look, guys. I had no intention of running for president again, for real. Or running for office. I was a professor at the University of Pennsylvania
如果我对他的政治观点一无所知，我和他其实相处得很好。我们能做些什么来试图找回这种状态？因为我认为这是你经常谈论的事情。好吧，我确实……看看，伙计们。我真的无意再次竞选总统，真的。或者竞选公职。我是宾夕法尼亚大学的教授，
and joined it and put together an institute up there. And when those folks came out of the fields, literally carrying torches down in Charlottesville, and the last guy said they're good people on both sides and that young woman was killed, I realized that we are at an inflection point in history. And it occurs every three, five, seven generations that what happens in the near term, in this case,
加入并建立了一个研究所。当那些家伙从田野里走出来，手里 literalmente 举着火炬在夏洛茨维尔游行，而上一个家伙说两边都有好人，并且那个年轻女子被杀害时，我意识到我们正处于历史的一个转折点。这种情况每三、五、七代人就会发生一次，即近期内发生的事情——在本案中，
the next two to three, five years, the last several years is gonna determine what it looks like for the next several generations. And the context was, my son had just died. And so we have a tradition in our family. Anyone in the family, any kid can ask for a family meeting. This is a dead series. I'm not joking about this.
也就是未来两到三、五年，过去几年的事情——将决定未来好几代人的面貌。当时的背景是，我的刚刚去世。所以我们家族有一个传统。家族中的任何人，任何孩子都可以要求召开家族会议。这是极其认真的。我不是在开玩笑。
As well as my dad's family when I was growing up. And so I got a call from my oldest granddaughter and saying, pop, we wanna have a family meeting. She was a freshman, either a senior at Penn or a freshman at Columbia Law. And then my other granddaughter is Finnegan Biden. She's a brilliant kid. She's at one of my secret weapon.
我小时候我爸爸的家里也是这样。所以我接到了我大孙女的电话，她说，外公，我们想开个家族会议。她当时是大一新生，要么是宾大即将毕业的大四学生，要么是哥伦比亚法学院的大一新生。然后我的另一个孙女是芬妮根·拜登。她是个聪明的孩子。她是我的一张秘密王牌。
She was, I think, a sophomore at Penn. And anyway. Couple of dummies, huh? Yeah, well, no, I don't mean that. I meant they were close to me, she was at my house. And then I had another granddaughter who was a senior in high school. And then a granddaughter who was a sophomore in high school
她当时，我想是宾大的大二学生。不管怎样。两个笨蛋，对吧？是的，不，我不是那个意思。我的意思是他们和我关系很近，她当时在我家。然后我还有另一个孙女是高中高三学生，
and a grandson who was thinking seventh or eighth grade. And they came in and they sat down and they said, pop, you really should run. And I didn't wanna run because I knew it was gonna be ugly. And keep in mind, just like your children in the show business, what, with your show business, they get used to the barbs, they get used to the accolades. And so they've been their whole life.
一个孙女是高二学生，还有一个孙孙大概是七、八年级的样子。他们走进来坐下，说，外公，你真的应该参选。我不想参选，因为我知道这会很难看。请记住，就像你们在演艺圈的孩子一样，你们的演艺圈生活，他们习惯了恶语中伤，他们习惯了赞誉。他们一生都在经历这些。
Either they've been a vice president or a senator and their dad or uncle had been attorney general and so on. And so they said, you gotta run, pop, pop, they call me pop. They said, pop, Uncle Bone want you to run, daddy want you to run, et cetera. And I said, what's gonna be, it's not gonna be very nice, honey. And my little guy, a little hunter,
要么他们当过副总统或参议员，他们的父亲或叔叔曾担任总检察长等等。所以他们说，你得参选，外公——他们叫我外公。他们说，外公，波恩叔叔想让你参选，爸爸想让你参选，等等。我说，这可不会太美好，亲爱的。我那个小家伙，小亨特，
he's now 16 years old, wonderful kid. He took out his cell phone, he said, here's a picture, pop, we know. And he showed me a picture. My wife hates me telling this story, but it's true. And it was a picture with me walking out of the cathedral with my hand on my son's flag-dread coffin, the military escort and my arm around him,
他现在16岁了，是个很棒的孩子。他掏出手机说，这是一张照片，外公，我们知道。他给我看了一张照片。我妻子讨厌我讲这个故事，但这是真的。那是一张我走出大教堂的照片，我的手放在我儿子盖着国旗的棺材上，有仪仗队护送，我的手臂搂着他，
like I used to hold his dad to just reassure me we're walking out. And the caption on the bottom said that Biden molests another child. And they said, we know it's gonna be tough. But here's the point about your question. I think the biggest thing that's changed is technology. There are no editors anymore.
就像我过去搂着他爸爸来安慰自己我们正走出去那样。底下的标题写着：拜登猥琐了另一个孩子。他们说，我们知道这会很艰难。但关于你的问题，我想说的是，我认为变化最大的是技术。现在已经没有编辑了。
And so, you know, there's a lot been written and I started to write a book about it. I don't, obviously, have time to do it now. That if you go all the way back to Gutenberg and the printing press, it changed the nature of the world and how nations got along. These guys have never read a book, so just keep going.
所以，你知道的，有很多关于这方面的文章，我曾开始写一本书。显然，我现在没有时间去写了。如果你一直追溯到古登堡和印刷机，它改变了世界的本质以及国家之间的相处方式。这些家伙从来没读过书，所以继续吧。
Well, I know. But look, look, I'm getting a television. But think about how things have changed and every new technological change, it changed the way we interface with one another. Whether it was a telegraph or the radio or then television. But now, the internet for the first time, there's no editors.
好吧，我懂。但听着，听着，我在看电视。但想想事情是如何改变的，每一次新技术的变革，都改变了我们彼此交互的方式。无论是电报、收音机还是后来的电视。但现在，互联网第一次没有了编辑。
There's no editors at all. And so, how does somebody know what is true? Yeah, and the difference between, you know, I think that you should do an executive order where you could do, you can post on the internet on social media, but you have to have your name, your address, and your phone number. And then we'll see if people change their tone a little bit.
完全没有任何编辑。那么，一个人怎么知道什么是真是假呢？是的，而且不同于……我认为你应该颁布一项行政命令，允许人们在互联网上、在社交媒体上发帖，但你必须附上你的真实姓名、住址和电话号码。然后我们看看人们的语气会不会稍微变好一点。
Isn't there any way for the FCC or someone to put a rating system or the equivalent of saying, this is just opinion, this is actually facts. Oh, you've wanted this for a long time. Like you should be able to have to hit a certain threshold. You can't just, everything can't look the same. It should have a little qualified Twitter does it or did it with the last guy's tweets.
难道就没有办法让联邦通信委员会或其他机构设立一个评分系统，或者说相当于贴上标签：这只是观点，这才是事实？哦，你早就想要这个了。就像你应该达到某个门槛一样。你不能只是，每样东西看起来都一样。它应该带有一点限定标签——推特就是这么做的，或者在上一个家伙发推时这么做过。
I mean, we live in an age where people decided to start politicizing science and medicine that it's so absurd. And you go, you know, I'm originally Canadian and I go back to Canada. I am American now, sir. But- If I defect, I'm going to Canada.
我的意思是，我们生活在一个人们决定将科学和医学政治化的时代，这太荒谬了。你会说，你知道的，我原本是加拿大人，我回过去加拿大。我现在是美国人，先生。但是……如果我叛逃，我要去加拿大。
Yeah, I will listen. And you can stay with my phone. I'll drive you. Jim and Alex will take you any day. But that idea that like, how, it's absurd. How are we politicizing this stuff that we used to take as facts? Well, look, that's true.
是的，我会听着的。你可以住在我那儿。我开车送你。吉姆和亚历克斯随时愿意带你走。但那种想法，怎么说呢，太荒谬了。我们怎么能把这些曾经被我们视为事实的东西政治化呢？好吧，听着，这是真的。
And if you notice the generic polling about the American public, they're 40, 50, 60, 100 worried about the survival of democracy. But it's not just here. It's all around the world. This notion of, can democracy, can it be sustained? But I'm optimistic and I really am.
如果你注意到关于美国公众的一般民意调查，他们中有40%、50%、60%、100%的人担心民主的生存。但这不仅仅发生在这里。全世界都是如此。这种关于民主能否维持下去的观念……但我很乐观，我真的是。
I love that. No, but I genuinely am because this younger generation, the ones you speak to, up to, I set to 30 when I saw it about the younger generation. No, I'm not being facetious. I'm being deadly earnest. Is the best educated, the most open, the least prejudice, the most giving generation in American history?
我太喜欢这个了。不，但我确实是发自内心地乐观，因为这个年轻一代，就是你们向其喊话的这一代——我看到年轻一代时，我说到了30岁。不，我不是在开玩笑。我是极其认真的。这是美国历史上受教育程度最高、最开放、偏见最少、最无私的一代？
And we're going to break through this. We really, truly are. And you think about the things that how ugly things have gotten, but think about how much we've gotten done. I mean, did, you know, when I ran, I said I was running for three reasons. Restore the soul of America, to rebuild the middle class.
我们将突破这一关。我们真的、确确实实会做到的。你想象事情变得多么糟糕，但想想我们已经完成了多少成就。我的意思是，你知道的，当我参选时，我说我参选出于三个原因：重塑美国的灵魂，重建中产阶级。
And because when the economy is built from the middle out, the poor do have a road up and the wealthy still do very well. And to unite the country. The third part's being the hardest because I went through my career as being the guy who got a lot done with Democrats and Republicans
因为当经济从中间向外构建时，穷人确实有了上升的通道，富人也依然过得很好。以及团结国家。第三部分是最难的，因为我整个职业生涯都是作为一个能在民主党和共和党人之间促成许多事情的人，
for all those years I was in the Senate. Hell, I was there for 36. You started when you, you were 29 when you became a Senator. Yeah, and I, and what's got me involved was the, I came from a state to its great shame, was segregated by law. And we have the eighth largest black population in America.
在我当参议员的那些年里。天哪，我在那儿待了36年。你开始时——你成为参议员时才29岁。是的，而我，让我参与其中的是，我来自一个有着巨大耻辱的州——它曾由法律实行种族隔离。我们拥有美国第八大黑人群体。
And I was really moved by the civil rights movement as a kid. And I remember we moved down from Scranton, Pennsylvania when Cole died. My dad was not a coal miner, but he was a salesperson. And we moved back to this little town called Clamont Delaware. And it used to be a big steel town. And we lived in what became projects,
我小时候真的被民权运动深深感动了。我记得科尔去世后，我们从宾夕法尼亚州的斯克兰顿搬了下来。我爸爸不是煤矿工人，但他是个推销员。我们搬回了一个叫克莱蒙特·特拉华的小镇。它曾经是个钢铁重镇。我们住在后来变成经济适用房的地方，
but at the time they were apartment complexes that were modest compared to where we had lived. And I went to a little Catholic school called Holy Rosary and it was across the street from the fire station there. And I remember my mom used to drive us up to school. I was in third grade and drop us in the park and allowed to go into school.
但在当时，那是与我们以前住过的地方相比很简陋的公寓大楼。我上了一所叫圣玫瑰的天主教小学校，它对面就是消防局。我记得我妈妈经常开车带我们去学校。我上三年级，她把我们放在公园里，允许我们自己走进学校。
And I see this bus go by all the time with only, then we referred to as colored, but black children in it. I didn't understand it. Because they didn't know it. There were hardly any black people in Scranton. And what was that all about? I said, well, they're not allowed to go to school, honey.
我看到一辆公交车经常开过去，上面只有——当时我们称之为有色人种，但实际上是黑人儿童。我不明白。因为他们对此一无所知。斯克兰顿几乎没有什么黑人。那到底是怎么回事？我说，哦，他们不被允许上学，亲爱的。
They're not allowed to go to the public schools here. And then I ended up being the only white employee in the east side of Wilmington, which is 98% African-American. I was a lifeguard there. And then I got involved in, and that's what got me engaged. So that was very inspiring for you. Well, it was, but it also was very angry.
他们不准去那里的公立学校。后来我成了威尔明顿东区唯一的白人雇员，那里98%都是非裔美国人。我在那里当救生员。后来我参与其中，这就是让我投入的原因。所以这对你来说非常鼓舞人心。嗯，是的，但也让人非常生气。
I mean, it made me angry. And like a lot of folks, my generation. And I love reading how I knew I was gonna run for president and I knew I was gonna be. I wouldn't even, I wasn't even old enough. I mean, I'll never forget. I got really involved trying to bring the Democratic Party in Delaware
我是说，这让我很生气。就像我这一代的许多人一样。我喜欢阅读，我怎么知道我要竞选总统，我知道我要成为。我甚至都不会，我当时甚至还不到法定年龄。我是说，我永远不会忘记。我全身心地投入到试图把特拉华州的民主党
into the mainstream and Northeastern Democrats. It was more a Southern Democratic Party. You're a Southern part of my state to Delmarva Peninsula. Talk cats like this, it's just very Southern for real. It's right at the Mason-Dixon line, right? Yeah, it actually goes north-south. Most people don't realize that, but yes, it is. And the end result of all that was
带入主流，还有东北部的民主党人。这更像是一个南方的民主党人。你是我所在的特尔玛瓦半岛的南方部分。听听这些家伙的说话方式，这真的很南方。它就在梅森-迪克森线旁，对吧？是的，它其实是南北走向的。大多数人没有意识到这一点，但确实是的。这一切的最终结果是
that I got involved, I was a young lawyer. I went to law school and I went to work for a guy who was a local, he was a state rep. He was a great trial lawyer. And one thing led to another and they tried to reform the Democratic Party to make it more, I mean, the Republican Party was more liberal than the Democratic Party.
我参与进去了，我当时是个年轻律师。我上了法学院，去给一个当地人工作，他是个州众议员。他是个出色的出庭律师。事情就这样一桩接一桩，他们试图改革民主党，让它变得更……我是说，共和党当时比民主党还要更自由派。
At the time I was a Rockefeller Republican. Anyway, to make a long story, not quite so long and boring, I was asked to help put together a group of young people to get someone to run for the United States Senate. And I kept working on it. And I went to an off-year convention in Dover, you know, the Democratic Convention. And I was, it was between the evening,
当时我是个洛克菲勒共和党人。总之，长话短说，没那么长也没那么无聊，有人请我帮忙组建一个年轻人团体，去找个人来竞选美国参议员。我一直为此努力。我去过多佛的一个非大选年党代会，你知道的，就是民主党代表大会。当时正处于傍晚，
the afternoon and evening session, and I was in a motel, small motel down there, shaven, and I was in the bathroom and I had a towel on and shaven cream and I was bangin' the door. And I opened the door and there's four leading Democrats, two of which I'd never met before, the two former governors and a state chairman
下午和晚上的会议之间，我待在一个汽车旅馆里，下面那个小汽车旅馆，在刮胡子，我当时在浴室里，身上围着一条毛巾，涂着剃须膏，有人在使劲敲门。我打开门，外面站着四个民主党大人物，其中有两个我以前从没见过，两个前州长和一个州党主席，
and a head of the Supreme Court who had retired and family, more senators than any family American history, the tunnels. And I was, I thought it was the guys I drove down with. I was 27, 28 years old. And I said, we gotta talk to you, Joe. We just had a dinner together. And I said, okay, gentlemen, I walked in
还有一位退休的最高法院院长以及他们的家属，美国历史上出过最多参议员的家族，那些泰斗们。我当时以为是和我一起开车下来的那些家伙。我当时27、28岁。我说，我们得跟你谈谈，乔。我们刚一起吃过晚饭。我说，好的，先生们，我走进去，
and quickly got in the bathroom, thinking there was a towel. I all had a towel, wiped the shaven cream on my face, came out and you know, there was desks that are nailed to the wall and the headboards nailed. And I'm leaning against the desk and they said, Joe, we were thinking you should run for the Senate. I said, oh, I said, no, I said,
迅速钻进浴室，以为里面有条毛巾。我赶紧抓了条毛巾，擦掉脸上的剃须膏，走出来，你知道的，那里有钉在墙上的桌子和钉在墙上的床头板。我靠着桌子，他们说，乔，我们觉得你应该去竞选参议员。我说，哦，我说，不，我说，
You said, can I get dressed? No, no, no, I'm serious, it's true story. And the Chief Justice, the former Justice said, I said, I'm not old enough, sir. He said, you obviously didn't do well in constitutional law, Joe. Said you don't have to be 30 to get elected. You had to be 30 to be sworn in.
你说，我能先穿好衣服吗？不，不，不，我是认真的，这是真事。那位首席大法官，前大法官说，我说，我还没到法定年龄，先生。他说，乔，你的宪法课显然学得不太好。他说，你当选时不需要满30岁。你宣誓就职时才需要满30岁。
And I remember going home and I don't know what you guys ever did. Inspired a great professor in high school and college. No, they never did. No, no, no, no. But I mean, there was a guy that I wasn't a good student either. If you're implying they weren't. No, they weren't students at all.
我记得回到家后，我不知道你们俩有没有做过。从高中和大学里的一位伟大教授那里获得灵感。不，他们从没做过。不，不，不，不。但我的意思是，曾经有个人，我也不是个好学生。如果你暗示他们不是的话。不，他们根本不是学生。
But here's the point, I got from riding home and I stopped at the University of Delaware the next day. I had a professor named David Ingersoll. He was my political philosophy professor. And I said, they used to ask me, this is crazy. And he looked at me, he said, Joe, remember what Plato said? And I'm thinking, what the hell did Plato say?
但重点是，我从骑车回家，第二天在特拉华大学停了下来。我有一位教授叫大卫·英格索尔。他是我的政治哲学教授。我说，他们以前问过我，这太疯狂了。他看着我，他说，乔，还记得柏拉图说过的话吗？我在想，柏拉图到底说了什么？
And he said, the privilege that apparently good people will pay for not being involved in politics is being governed by people worse than themselves. And it was the middle of Vietnam war and a lot of our things going on. One thing led to another. Oh, the penalty for not voting. Yeah.
他说，不参与政治的体面人所付出的代价，就是被比他们更差的人统治。当时正值越南战争中期，发生了许多事情。一桩接一桩。哦，不投票的惩罚。是的。
I used to play with Plato as a kid. Yeah. See, I told you, by the way, I wasn't a good student either. This is just an inside joke to torture them. Mr. President, your ability to, as you always have, across the aisle and broker these great agreements, if somebody who was, what would you say, you were 29 at the time, 29 now coming into politics
我小时候经常和柏拉图一起玩。是的。你看，我早就说过，顺便说一句，我以前也不是个好学生。这只是个折磨他们的内部笑话。总统先生，你一直以来都有跨越党派分歧、促成这些伟大协议的能力，如果有人，你会怎么说，你当时29岁，现在29岁步入政坛，
with how dynamic this political culture is and the necessity, the vital that we come across the aisle to one another, what would you suggest to them? What's the secret sauce to be able to do that? How do you identify things that both sides could get excited about? You know, because I got elected so young, everybody thought there had to be some secret sauce I had.
面对如此充满活力的政治文化，以及跨越党派分歧、彼此走近的必要性和紧迫性，你会对他们有什么建议？能够做到这一点的秘密武器是什么？你如何找出能让双方都感到兴奋的事情？你知道的，因为我当选时太年轻了，每个人都以为我有什么秘密武器。
I had no, you know, there must have been something. And so I've had, that's about everybody's ever sought the office of the senator, governor, young person in the last 40 years of the economy. They say, you know, what is it? And I say the same thing and I mean it from the bottom of my heart. I said, figure out, what are you willing to lose over?
我根本没有，你知道的，一定有什么东西。所以过去40年来，每一个谋求参议员、州长职务的年轻人，我都遇到过。他们说，你知道，那是什么？我说的是同样的话，我是发自内心地说的。我说，弄清楚，你愿意为什么事情而输？
Yeah. Or don't get involved? Because if you don't know what you're willing to lose over and have something that important to you, don't get engaged, don't get involved running because it can make a lot of money and do a lot better doing other things than being in politics. And so one of the things that does is that, you know,
是的。或者干脆别参与？因为如果你不知道自己愿意为什么事情而输，也没有什么对你如此重要的话，就不要介入，不要去竞选，因为从政之外，做别的事情可以赚很多钱，也过得更好。所以其中一件事就是，你知道的，
there's a joke among my colleagues when I said it, no one ever doubts I mean what I say. The problem is I sometimes say all that I mean. We'll be right back. Thank you, Rocket Money for your support. Listener, do you know how much your subscriptions really cost? Most Americans think they spend about 80 bucks a month
我的同事们中间有个笑话，当我这么说时，从来没有人怀疑过我是认真的。问题是，有时我把我想表达的都说出来了。我们马上回来。谢谢 Rocket Money 对本节目的支持。听众朋友们，你知道你的订阅服务实际花掉了多少钱吗？大多数美国人认为他们每月在订阅上花大约80美元，
on subscriptions when the actual total is closer to $200 plus. That's right. You could be wasting hundreds of dollars each month on subscriptions. You don't even know about. There is this app we're very excited about that takes care of all of that for you.
而实际总额接近甚至超过200美元。没错。你可能每个月都在那些你甚至都不知道的订阅上浪费几百美元。我们有一款非常兴奋的应用程序，它能帮你搞定这一切。
And it's called, I said it earlier, Rocket Money. They're formerly known as True Bill but Rocket Money is just so much more fun to say, right? This app shows you all your subscriptions in one place and then it cancels for you whatever you don't still want. Rocket Money can even find subscriptions you didn't even know you were paying for. You may even find out that you were double charged
它叫做——我刚才说过了——Rocket Money。它们以前叫 True Bill，但 Rocket Money 听起来更有趣，对吧？这款应用把你的所有订阅都显示在一个地方，然后帮你取消那些你不再需要的订阅。Rocket Money 甚至能找出那些你连自己都在掏钱订阅的服务。你甚至可能会发现你被重复扣费了，
for a subscription, it's just, it takes care of so much. To cancel a subscription, all you have to do is press cancel. And Rocket Money is gonna take care of the rest. Let's get rid of all the useless subscriptions with Rocket Money right now. Let's go to rocketmoney.com slash smart list. Seriously, it could save you hundreds of dollars per year. That's rocketmoney.com slash smart list.
一项订阅，它就是……它能帮你处理太多事情了。要取消订阅，你只需要按一下“取消”。剩下的就交给 Rocket Money 来处理吧。让我们现在就用 Rocket Money 摆脱所有无用的订阅吧。访问 rocketmoney.com/smartlist。说真的，它每年能帮你省下几百美元。网址是 rocketmoney.com/smartlist。
Cancel your unnecessary subscriptions right now at rocketmoney.com slash smart list. I'm not gonna say it again. I'm not gonna say it again. Smart list listener, we're supported by Farah Body. We always hear that movement is good for the mind and body and it's true, it's not false, it's true. How great do you feel after a long run
现在就去 rocketmoney.com/smartlist 取消你不需要的订阅吧。我不会再说第二遍了。我不会再说第二遍了。Smartless 的听众们，我们得到了 Farah Body 的赞助。我们总是听到运动对身心有益，这是真的，不是假的，千真万确。长跑之后
or after a quick meditation, right? We know movement is good for us, but sometimes it can be hard to do it. That's where Farah Body comes in. Their products are proven to help you move better throughout the entire day. Farah Body, the makers of the Farah Gun, now offer a suite of products that give you more ways
或者简短的冥想之后，你感觉多棒啊，对吧？我们知道运动对我们有益，但有时要坚持做很难。这就是 Farah Body 发挥作用的地方。事实证明，他们的产品可以帮助你在整整一天中更好地活动身体。Farah Body，Theragun 按摩枪的制造商，现在推出了一系列产品，为你提供更多方式
to care for your body and mind. The Farah Gun is amazing. We're big fans, it can help improve your pain, performance, stress, and sleep. But don't just take our word for it. Every product is backed by science and tested by experts. And check this out, there's a new Farah Gun Pro, which is the world's best massage device.
来关爱你的身心。Theragun 按摩枪太棒了。我们都是它的超级粉丝，它能帮你缓解疼痛、提升表现、减轻压力和改善睡眠。但不要只听我们的一面之词。每一款产品都有科学支撑，并经过专家的测试。来看看这个，全新的 Theragun Pro 是世界上最好的按摩设备。
It's smarter, quieter, and powerful with recovery that lasts longer than the competition. Plus the new Farah Gun Mini, which is smaller and lighter than ever, without sacrificing Farah Gun's signature power. It goes wherever you do, which is great for us while we're traveling. I've owned a Farah Gun forever and I love it.
它更智能、更安静、动力强劲，且续航时间比竞争对手更持久。此外还有全新的 Theragun Mini，它比以往更小、更轻，同时却没有牺牲 Theragun 的标志性动力。它随身携带，非常适合我们在旅行时使用。我拥有 Theragun 很久了，我爱死它了。
I use it all the time and it really, really works and it really, really helps. I even use it at the gym. When I go to the gym, like right afterwards, to soothe my muscles from working hard. So when you see me in person, if you've ever seen me in person, you'll see how jacked I am.
我一直在用它，它真的、真的很有用，真的、真的很有帮助。我甚至在健身房也用它。我去健身房锻炼完之后，就会马上用它来舒缓努力锻炼后的肌肉。所以当你亲自见到我时，如果你曾经亲自见过我，你就会看到我的肌肉有多么健美。
That's, I may look jacked, but I'm also really relaxed. That's because of the Farah Gun. Anyway, Farah Body, keep moving. Farah Gun is the perfect gift or snag it for yourself. To get 15% off a Farah Gun, go to farahbody.com and use the code word smartless. That's farahbody.com code smartless. And now back to the show.
那……我看起来可能很健美，但我其实也非常放松。这都要归功于 Theragun。总之，Farah Body，保持运动。Theragun 是完美的礼物，或者给自己买一个吧。想要享受 Theragun 85折优惠，请访问 farahbody.com 并使用优惠码 smartless。网址是 farahbody.com，优惠码是 smartless。现在回到我们的节目。
Mr. President, we, this is, you know, we're not qualified or smart enough to ask you great questions. So what we'd like to do, I would love to know just some of the, just the simple sort of human stuff. I want to know, to the extent you're comfortable telling us, like just like the dumb stuff in your life. You want to know his personal stuff?
总统先生，我们，你知道的，我们不够资格也没有那么聪明，无法向你提出什么了不起的问题。所以我们想做的是，我很想了解一些，只是一些简单的人情世故。我想知道，在你感到舒适的范围内，比如你生活中的那些蠢事。你想了解他的私事？
His personal stuff, yeah. Yeah, he's a person. What time do you get up most mornings? And do you use an alarm clock? I get a staff call. I have an alarm, but they don't trust that. So I need, my routine is there's a great guy who used to be a physical therapist at the, at the White House.
他的私事，对。对，他是个普通人。你大部分早晨几点起床？你用闹钟吗？会有工作人员打电话叫醒我。我有闹钟，但他们不信任那个。所以我需要，我的常规是，白宫里有一位很棒的前理疗师，
Now he comes in. I, What do you mean he comes in? He comes in and he gently rocks you? He doesn't rock me. I tell you what, he works me when I go up. There's a gym upstairs and so eight o'clock I, I'm up at seven, seven, 15.
现在他会过来。我……你什么意思，他会过来？他会过来轻轻摇醒你吗？他不会摇醒我。我跟你说，我起床时他会帮我松骨。楼上有个健身房，所以我8点钟……我7点、7点15起床，
I go up and work out from eight until a quarter of nine. And what are we doing up there? We, we, we, we blast him back and buy. Well, yes. As a matter of fact. Oh, I love it. You look like you're in great shape. Yeah.
我上去锻炼，从8点锻炼到8点45。我们在上面做什么？我们……我们在锻炼胸肌和背部。嗯，是的。事实上。哦，我太喜欢了。你看起来身材保持得真好。对。
Well, I feel good. I feel good. I, the thing I learned the difference in age, if I let it go for a week, I feel it. I know, right? Again, he's looking at you, Sean. Go ahead. Wait, no, I used to be able to go for a week
嗯，我感觉很好。我感觉很好。我，我体会到年龄差异的一点是，如果我偷懒一个星期不锻炼，我身体就能感觉得到。我懂，对吧？你看，他又在看你了，肖恩。继续。等等，不，我以前可以偷懒一个星期
and nothing would change. And I was like, no, it's true though. It's not serious. Believe me, we're all over 50 and we notice, we talk about it all the time, how much harder it is getting on top of it now. What's your, what's your kryptonite? If something's in front of you, it's going to get eaten.
什么都不做，身体也不会有任何变化。我就想……不，不过这是真的。这不是开玩笑。相信我，我们都过50岁了，我们都有所体会，我们一直在讨论现在保持状态有多难。你的……你的软肋是什么？如果有某种东西摆在你面前，你一定会把它吃光。
What is it? I know what it is. Is it French fries? Oh, I know what it is. Hang on, hang on, I know what it is. It's the same thing. It's ice cream. And I'm going to, and Sean and I are both-
那是什么？我知道是什么。是薯条吗？哦，我知道是什么。等等，等等，我知道是什么。是一样的。是冰淇淋。而且我……肖恩和我都是……
Chocolate chip. Oh boy. That's what I wanted to ask. I like chocolate chips. I'm a ice cream, I will- I'm a dollar's hell. I'm known for my Ray-Ban sunglasses and chocolate chip. I wanted to, so I wanted to also say that the Ray-Bans,
巧克力曲奇味。哦，天哪。这就是我想问的。我喜欢巧克力曲奇。我是个冰淇淋……我是个死忠粉。我以我的雷朋太阳镜和巧克力曲奇闻名。我还想说的是，雷朋眼镜，
I mean, this is the greatest look of a president, all president- You're the coolest guy in the world. Yeah, of course, we're Ray-Bans. By the way, all those years, when I ran for the first time for the Senate, I had been up to that point, even though I was a practicing lawyer,
我是说，这是历任总统中最帅的造型……你是世界上最酷的家伙。对，当然，我们戴着雷朋。顺便说一句，当年我第一次竞选参议员时，在此之前，尽管我是一名执业律师，
in order to get free rent, there was a country swimming club that had 17 acres, a little tiny house on it. And they let us live in the house as long as I would hire all the pool people, right? Sure. But all from the time I was 16, I was a lifeguard, I did all I ever did.
为了能住上免费的房子，有一个乡村游泳俱乐部，占地17英亩，上面有一座很小的小房子。他们让我们住在那个房子里，只要我负责雇佣所有的泳池工作人员，对吧？当然。但从我16岁起，我就是个救生员，我做过的一切就只有这个。
So the headline was, you don't want this guy, the only job he's ever had is a lifeguard. By the way, I'm like, yeah, he's like ripped in pants and wearing sunglasses. By the way, the guy before you, he didn't even need sunglasses. He would just look at it in a clip. I want to, I want to, first of all,
所以当时的头条新闻是，你可不想选这家伙，他唯一干过的职业就是救生员。顺便说一句，我就像……是的，他就像是穿着破洞裤还戴着墨镜。顺便说一句，你前面的那个人，他甚至都不需要墨镜。他只会眯着眼睛看。我想……首先，
I want, first of all, there's no reason coconut should ever be an ice cream. I just wanted to say that. I like coconut. Yeah, I like coconut. I like coconut ice cream. Coconut is a country pie. Well, coconut pie is fine, but not an ice cream.
我想……首先，椰子根本没有资格成为冰淇淋的口味。我只是想这么说。我喜欢椰子。对，我喜欢椰子。我喜欢椰子冰淇淋。椰子是乡村派的馅料。嗯，椰子派可以，但做成冰淇淋就不行了。
I can't do the ice cream. I'm a simple plain veneer. More for us. Anyway, here's the thing. I want to know about suits. How many suits? Yeah, yeah, I had the same question. Right?
我受不了这种冰淇淋。我的口味很单一朴素。那留给我们更多。不管怎样，重点是。我想了解西装。你有多少套西装？对，对，我也有同样的问题。对吧？
You only need like two or three. Nobody's picking. Who's picking the suit in the morning? Yeah, and like me. Really? So you've got a big closet. Yeah, no, I have, I guess I have a, I have. Less than a hundred or more than a hundred?
你只需要两三套就够了。没有人会在意。早上是谁帮你挑西装的？对，而且像我这样。真的吗？所以你有一个很大的衣柜。对，没有，我猜我有一个……不到100套还是超过100套？
I have probably less than 15. Less than 15. More than 14. But a lot of ties. A lot of ties. A lot of ties. You can get sassy with the ties. Do you choose ties too?
我可能不到15套。不到15套。多于14套。但有很多领带。有很多领带。有很多领带。你可以在领带上搞点花样。领带也是你自己选的吗？
Yeah. Yeah. Jill doesn't, does Jill ever give you the hairy eyeball? Like, no, please. What do you do with that? Well, she is, if I'm not. I'm sure, you must mean Mrs. Biden. Well, what would it be?
对。是的。吉尔从来……吉尔有没有给你翻过白眼？比如，不，求你了。你怎么处理这个？嗯，她会，如果我没有……我确凿地说，你一定是指拜登夫人。嗯，还能是谁？
Oh, Jill's fine. The first lady. The first lady. Jill's fine. Joe's fine. Oh, get in the side. No, I'm very nervous. No, no, and, but it's, she gets very upset
哦，吉尔很好。第一夫人。第一夫人。吉尔很好。乔很好。哦，别掺和了。不，我非常紧张。不，不，而且，她会很不高兴
if I have not fully shaven or all this excessive amount of hair I have, you know what I mean? What do you do with that? I know how you feel. I think we suffer from the same problem. No, wait, just, you know, I want to get back to just one second. Back to ice cream though.
如果我没有刮干净胡子，或者我头上留着这些过多的头发，你知道我的意思吗？你怎么处理这个？我懂你的感受。我想我们都有同样的困扰。不，等等，你知道的，我想回到刚才的话题，就一秒钟。不过还是回到冰淇淋上来。
No, you've obviously accomplished so many, so many amazing things in your presidency so far, one of which is the Inflation Reduction Act, which I was excited about because of global warming, because I hate the heat. I want the temperatures to go down. When it's hot, I get irritable. What's that to do with inflation?
不，你在总统任期内显然已经取得了如此之多、如此惊人的成就，其中之一就是《通货膨胀削减法案》，我对它感到兴奋是因为全球变暖，因为我讨厌炎热。我希望气温下降。天气热的时候我会变得烦躁。这跟通货膨胀有什么关系？
Oh my God. No, it's inside the Inflation Reduction Act. It's the global warming thing. All gonna read one day. But is the ship sailed on fixing this climate thing? Like, is there anything we can do? Oh, should we just give up? No.
哦，天哪。不，它包含在《通货膨胀削减法案》里面。就是那个全球变暖的事情。大家总有一天会去读的。但是，修复气候问题的这艘船已经开走了吗？比如，我们还有什么能做的吗？哦，我们应该直接放弃吗？不。
You asking the question? No, I meant like what's, is there any hope? Is there any hope? There's a lot of hope. Okay, good. There's a lot of hope because two things, for example, I'm out here. With you at the wheel, there's hope.
你在问这个问题吗？不，我的意思是，还有希望吗？还有希望吗？有很多希望。好的，很好。有很多希望，因为有两件事，例如，我来到这里。有你掌舵，就有希望。
Well, I'm out here today with Congresswoman Bass, Karen Bass, and I go over, they have a rapid transition here that needs a lot of work. Well, we're gonna spend $9 billion making a change. But here's the deal. It's estimated to take 124,000 tons out of the air. Let me back up.
好吧，我今天和众议员巴斯、凯伦·巴斯一起来到这里，我过去看看，他们这里有一个需要大量改进的快速公交系统。好吧，我们要花90亿美元来进行变革。但重点是，据估计，这可以从空气中减少124,000吨（碳排放）。让我退回一步。
If people have a chance to get on a track train and can make it quicker than they can driving their car, they take the train. Yeah, very traffic. And I'm a big train guy. And we've gotten billions of dollars more from, we're spending more on Amtrak than Amtrak initially was spent. And it's all just getting underway.
如果人们有机会坐上轨道列车，而且比他们开车更快的话，他们就会选择坐火车。是的，交通非常拥堵。而且我是个坚定的火车迷。我们从……获得了更多的数十亿美元，我们在美铁（Amtrak）上的花费超过了美铁最初的花费。这一切才刚刚开始。
But it's fundamental changes that are gonna be taking place. And there's so much. And it really does work too. I noticed during COVID, when everyone was having to stay inside here in LA, the skies were, in a week, they were crystal clear. It really does work. I thought you were gonna say,
但这是将要发生的根本性变革。而且还有很多。这确实很管用。我注意到在新冠疫情期间，当每个人都不得不呆在洛杉矶的室内时，天空在短短一周内就变得晶莹剔透。这确实管用。我还以为你要说，
I noticed too that the roads were really empty and I could just bomb around. No. But they were, the air out here, as you know, his story came out. Well, I know, and this is gonna be a game changer. It's gonna take some... I'm so excited about it.
我也注意到道路非常空旷，我可以到处飙车。不是的。但它们确实很空，这里的空气，如你所知，历史记载就摆在那里。嗯，我知道，这将是一个彻底的改变。这需要一些……我对此感到非常兴奋。
And by the way, in addition to the $368 billion for climate in that bill, we also have over a trillion, $200 billion that we got passed in the act having to do with dealing with infrastructure. We used to rank number one in the world in infrastructure. We're number 13 for God's sake. We used to, I mean...
顺便说一句，除了该法案中用于气候的3,680亿美元外，我们还在基础设施法案中通过了超过1.2万亿美元的资金。我们过去在基础设施方面排名世界第一看在上帝的份上，我们现在排在第13位。我们过去常常，我是说……
And this is a lot of jobs. A lot of jobs. Literally, we've created more jobs in the first 18 months than any present history. 700,000 manufacturing jobs. Where the hell does it say America can't be the manufacturing job in the world? Manufacturing's gone now.
而这创造了大量的就业机会。大量的就业机会。真的，我们在前18个月里创造的就业机会比历史上任何一位总统都要多。70万个制造业工作岗位。凭什么美国就不能成为世界上的制造业中心？制造业现在已经消失了。
And all that... Wrong, wrong, wrong, wrong. Yeah, and it is a little shocking that how much of that has been lost, and it does fill me with hope with the idea that we can get manufacturing back. Well, you know why it got lost? We used to spend 2% of our GDP
所有这些……错、错、错、错。是的，令人震惊的是，其中有多少已经丢失了，这也让我对我们能够恢复制造业的想法充满了希望。你知道为什么它会丢失吗？我们过去将 GDP 的 2% 用于
on research and development as a nation. We're down to 0.7%. China's past, other countries are passing us by. But now we're going back to, look, my major goal in terms of the economy was to change the dynamic of trickle-down economy to building from the middle-out, bottom-up, and doing it that way.
在全国研发投入方面。我们的比例降到了0.7%。中国已经超过了我们，其他国家也正在超越我们。但现在我们正在重回正轨，看吧，我关于经济的主要目标，就是改变那种“涓滴经济学”的动态，转变为从中间向外、从底层向上的建设方式，并通过这种方式来实现发展。
And I know I get criticized and understandably for being, quote, the most pro-union president in history. Well, the reason for that is these union folks, everybody thinks they show up and on a job, and you can be a technician. Guess what? You take four or five years, it's like going back to college.
我知道我受到了批评，而且可以理解，因为我是历史上“最支持工会的总统”。好吧，原因在于这些工会的人，每个人都认为他们出现在工作岗位上，你可以成为一名技术员。你猜怎么着？你需要花四到五年时间，这就像重返大学一样。
It's like going to school. They're the best in the world. They're the best in the world. And they're all the way, it's cheaper for it. So there's a lot we're doing. And for example, we're going to invest literally several hundred billion dollars in building chips or computer computers.
就像上学一样。它们是世界上最好的。它们是世界上最好的。而且一路走来，它的成本更低。所以我们正在做很多事情。例如，我们将字面投资数千亿美元用于制造芯片或计算机。
We invented them. We invented them. Yeah, yeah, yeah. So important. So anyway. Trickle-down economics. I want to go find a billionaire and give him 10 grand because I know it'll get to the little guy.
我们发明的。我们发明的。对，对，对。太重要了。所以无论如何。涓滴经济学。我想去找个亿万富翁给他一万块，因为我知道这最终会惠及底层普通人。
With the, I've got a fairly adult question here. So I've written it out. I apologize for reading. Oh, well, we'll judge if it's adult. With the midterms on our doorstep, okay. Two thirds of the seats that are up for grabs in the midterms are trending to be won by admitted election deniers.
嗯，我这里有一个相当成熟的问题。所以我把它写下来了。我为读稿道歉。哦，好吧，我们会判断它是否成熟。期中选举即将来临，好吧。期中选举中三分之二的席位正倾向于被承认的选举否定论者赢得。
And then that means that elections and consequently democracy as a form of government will most likely be done away with or could be seriously threatened. This is what they're saying that their plan is once elected. So doesn't that current real forecast, even declaration, justify some kind of emergency alert that asks for maximum attention and participation
然后这意味着选举，进而作为一种政府形式的民主，极有可能会被废除，或者受到严重威胁。这是他们所说的当选后的计划。那么，这种当前的真实预测，甚至是宣言，难道不足以证明某种需要最高度关注和参与的紧急警报是正当的吗？
from every single voter in America? No advocation for Republican or Democrat, just a request to vote in this midterm election. Could I ask you to commit to consider over the next few days using your unique powers president to utilize the emergency alert system for the listener. This is the system that's in place to alert citizens of impending danger.
来自美国的所有选民？不偏袒共和党或民主党，只是请求在这场期中选举中投票。总统先生，我能请您承诺在接下来几天里，考虑利用您的独特权力，为听众启动紧急警报系统吗？这就是用来向公民发出迫在眉睫危险警报的系统。
Yes, it's usually for the weather or killers or kidnapping, whatever. But I don't think it's an exaggeration to categorize this as a light crisis, an existential threat. Just ask the families of the COVID victims what danger is with poor leadership or the citizens of Russia or Ukraine, what happens when the electoral process is merely a facade.
是的，通常是为了天气、杀手或绑架之类的事情。但我不认为将其归类为一场轻度危机或生存威胁是夸大其词。只要问问新冠死者的家属，糟糕的领导会带来什么样的危险，或者问问俄罗斯或乌克兰的公民，当选举过程只是走过场时会发生什么。
So our TV and radio outlets are required to deliver presidential alerts. And all this would be to simply to air once a night leading up to election day on every TV satellite and cable channel, a quick 10 second card that just simply says, please vote on November 8th. That's all.
因此，我们的电视和广播媒体被要求发送总统警报。所有这些都只是为了在选举日前的每天晚上，在每个电视、卫星和有线电视频道上播放一次，一个简短的10秒卡片，上面只写着：请在11月8日投票。仅此而已。
That is a great idea. That's the way you can consider. First of all, great idea. And also officially with the president, the longest Bateman question ever, this simultaneously, and it's a great idea. But I understand you needed it. The point you're making is the point.
那是一个极好的主意。你可以这样考虑。首先，这是个好主意。而且在总统那里，这也是史上最长的巴特曼问题，同时发生，这真是个好主意。但我理解你需要它。你所表达的观点正是核心所在。
Just to get people out of the vote. Yeah. And look, you saw, I mean, the best example is the Supreme Court in the Dove's decision said, there's a line from one of the justices saying, women have a right to vote. We'll see it, but basically we'll see if they do. You saw what happened in Tennessee.
为了阻止人们投票。是的。而且你看到了吧，我意思是最佳的例子就是最高法院在多夫斯案的判决中，有位法官说过，女性有投票权。我们会看到的，但基本上我们会看他们是否会这么做。你看到了田纳西州发生了什么。
Women showed up and vote. Women are out registering men for the first time significantly for this new election. And that was immediate, wasn't it? I mean, that was immediate. And so my generic point is, I think people, particularly younger people, that's what I'm spending most of my time
妇女们站出来投票。妇女们在这个新选举中首次显著地帮助男性登记。那是立竿见影的，不是吗？我的意思是，那确实是立竿见影的。所以我的总体观点是，我认为人们，尤其是年轻人，这就是我花大部分时间的地方
trying to focus on, people under 30, they in fact understand the vote matters. What I worry about, I worry about the states that have the election deniers and I'm making it harder practically for them to vote. That's what I worry about the Supreme Court decisions on voting that are coming down, that are going to be coming down.
我试图关注的是，30岁以下的人实际上明白投票很重要。我担心的是那些有选举否定派的州，他们实际上让投票变得更加困难。这就是我所担忧的，最高法院即将做出或将要做出的关于投票的裁决。
And so, but vote, vote, vote. That's been my, I end all my speeches, everything I talk about. For me to do what you're suggesting, my imagination would end up being a gigantic fight, whether I was using an emergency system designed to save, quote, lives for political purposes. That's not.
所以，但是投票，投票，投票。这是我的，我结束所有的演讲，我谈论的一切。为了让我做你所建议的事情，我的想象力最终将变成一场巨大的争端，无论我是不是为了政治目的而使用旨在挽救生命的紧急系统。那不是。
No, it's not, but it's not for a Republican or a Democrat. It's just participating in the American process of voting. Just a quick 10 second, boo. Well, guess what? Well, it's great, but guess what? The whole idea is the other team doesn't want people to vote. They don't want open voting.
不，不是这样的，但这既不是为了共和党人，也不是为了民主党人。这只是参与美国的投票进程。只需短短10秒，嘘。好吧，你猜怎么着？好吧，这很好，但你猜怎么着？整个核心理念是另一方不想让人们投票。他们不希望开放投票。
They don't want to be able to mail in ballots. But they gotta do what the president says, at least until, while you're still president, you could put that little card up there, get everybody voting and save our elections. Well, we're paying to try to put that card up. It'd make a great movie, wouldn't it? Thank you, actor, Jason Bayman.
他们不想能寄回选票。但他们得听总统的话，至少在……当您还是总统时，您可以把那个小牌子举起来，让所有人都来投票，拯救我们的选举。好吧，我们花钱正是在努力把那个牌子举起来。这会是一部很棒的电影，不是吗？谢谢你，演员杰森·贝曼。
Hey, can I just say? I'm serious, Jason, you're right. No, he's a great, by the way, it's a great idea, and I really like that. I think that that's pretty awesome. It would be a good use of it, but I think you're right. It would be hijacked, if you will,
嘿，我能说吗？我是认真的，杰森，你是对的。不，他是个很棒的人，顺便说一句，这是个好主意，我真的很喜欢。我觉得这挺厉害的。这会是一个很好的用途，但我认为你是对的。如果可以这么说的话，它会被劫持的，
by people who would think that you were a blizzard. Well, they should do it one, you know, they're in charge too, I mean, it's just voting. I just want to say, Mr. President, what's crazy for us is we started this podcast in the middle of COVID when everybody else was locked down and we were too, and for us, it was a way to connect. We've been friends for 20 years.
那些会认为你是一场暴风雪的人。好吧，他们确实应该这么做，你知道的，他们也负责，我的意思是，这只是投票。我只想说，总统先生，对我们来说疯狂的是，我们在新冠疫情期间开始了这档播客，当时所有人都被封锁了，我们也是，对我们来说，这是一种联系的方式。我们已经是二十年的朋友了。
I get to do it with these two guys that I love a lot and who are my best friends. And we just started, we didn't know where we were going. It gives us a lot of joy to know that it gave people, that it uplifted people and made people feel more confident or made people feel more positive in a tough time. You gave them hope, look guys, two things are gonna go down in history.
我有幸能和这两个我很爱、也是我最好的朋友的家伙一起做这件事。我们刚开始时，并不知道会走向何方。得知它曾带给人们力量、鼓舞了人们、让大家在艰难时期感到更自信或更乐观，这让我们感到无比快乐。你们给了他们希望，听着，伙计们，有两件事将载入史册。
Number one, more than a million people died. A million people died. And the estimates are those million people had nine close related people, whether they're family or otherwise. The psychological impact on the nation has been profound, absolutely profound. And the other thing is the whole idea
第一，有一百多万人死亡。一百多万人死亡。据估计，这死去的百万人都各自关联着九位至亲或挚友，无论是家庭成员还是其他人。对这个国家造成的心理影响是深远的，绝对深远的。另一件事是整个概念
that we're moving, think about this. Graduating from when you graduated from high school, you had your prom, you had, you know, the graduation ceremonies yet. Well, what do these kids have? Kids are graduating. What are the things that they in fact missed that are consequential?
我们正在经历这一切，想想看。从你高中毕业的时候开始，你有毕业舞会，你知道的，还有毕业典礼。那么，这些孩子们有什么呢？孩子们正在毕业。他们实际上错过了哪些具有重要影响的事情呢？
That junior prom, that senior prom, that graduation ceremony, all those parties, all the, I mean, it's like, and it's like the difference. Everybody asked me what was the most exciting thing when you got elected and so on. You know, I was really honored to be, I mean, the greatest honor in the world, okay? But there was no celebration about it.
那个初中毕业舞会、那个高中毕业舞会、那个毕业典礼、所有那些派对、所有那些，我的意思是，这就像，这就像区别。每个人都问我，当你当选时最激动人心的事情是什么，诸如此类。你知道，我真的很荣幸能成为，我的意思是，世界上最高的荣誉，好吧？但对此并没有什么庆祝。
You're having to do rallies with cars honking. No, no, but I mean it. And that's not who we are. And the other thing people have to remember, our strength lies in our incredible diversity. It's incredible. Absolutely. And other nations are realizing that,
䙢䙢䙢䙢
that's why they want to invest here. That's why they want to get engaged here. Or come here for education. Exactly right. And so there's so much, and by the way, I'm convinced we're gonna be able to do a hell of a lot. I love that. Me too.
这就是他们想要在这里投资的原因。这也是他们想要在这里参与的原因。或者来这里接受教育。完全正确。所以有很多，顺便说一句，我相信我们能够做很多事情。我喜欢这样。我也是。
And I gotta tell you, during a time, I can speak for me, during a time that felt really hopeless and dark. And it felt like a number of years where the sort of the sentiment of the nation was quite dark. Mr. President, you brought a lot of light. So much.
我必须得告诉你，在一段时间里，我只能代表我自己，那段时期感觉真的非常绝望和黑暗。而且感觉有那么好几年，全国上下的情绪都十分阴暗。总统先生，您带来了很多光芒。真的非常多。
You did bring a lot of hope to a lot of people. Absolutely lightness. And we fed on that. And common sense. And I thank you so much for that. I think that you were able to light it towards you all. Well, the biggest thing, I say one more thing.
你的确给很多人带来了很多希望。绝对的轻松。我们从中汲取了力量。还有常识。对此我非常感谢你。我想你能把光芒引向你们所有人。好吧，最重要的一件事，我再多说一句。
One of the things is that people understand that I understand loss. Yes. And I think it's so important that people understand that from that loss, it's never, the pain never goes away, but you can do incredible things. The person you lost never leaves your heart.
其中有一点是，人们明白我懂得失去的滋味。是的。而且我认为让人们明白这一点非常重要：从那种失去中，痛苦永远不会消失，但你可以创造出不起的成就。你失去的那个人永远不会离开你的心。
I don't know how many times I ask myself, what would Beau do? I'm not joking. And so you just, there's so, people are genuinely empathetic if you give them a shot. And I think just reaching out to people, not me president, but just reaching out to people matters. Think of the number of people who are down and out
我不知道自己问过自己多少次，博会怎么做？我不是在开玩笑。所以只要你给别人一个机会，人们就会真正地感同身受。我认为主动接触他人——不是指我当总统，而是主动接触他人——这很重要。想想那些失意落魄的人的数量。
and wonder, where in the hell am I gonna go? What happens? Your empathy is genuine, it's sincere, it's infectious, and it's a pleasure to be led by you. Well, you guys are giving me more credit on my thank you. And thank you for the hope that you give to everybody. I really do, I am optimistic. I'm with you.
然后纳闷，我到底能去哪儿呢？会发生什么？你的同理心是真诚的、诚挚的、具有感染力的，能在你的领导下共事是一种荣幸。好吧，你们在感谢时给我的赞誉太高了。也谢谢你给每个人带来希望。我真的这么认为，我很乐观。我和你们站在一起。
I'm with you. You know, I will leave you, and we take, you know, we say this to everybody, we have taken up too much of your time. I have a friend of mine who always says, if you're feeling down, call five people and tell them how much you love them. Yeah.
我赞同你的看法。你知道的，我要走了，我们对每个人都这样说，我们占用了你太多时间。我有一个朋友总是说，如果你感到沮丧，给五个人打电话，告诉他们你有多爱他们。是的。
And you know what? It works. It does work. It does work. So give me your number. Yeah, if we can get just, it'll just be a text, I promise that it won't be, Mr. President, thank you so much.
你知道吗？这确实管用。真的管用。真的管用。所以把你的电话号码给我吧。对，如果我们能弄到一个，就发个短信就行，我保证不会是这样的，总统先生，非常感谢。
Thank you so much. Thank you guys. No, I really enjoyed it. Thank you. Thank you. Invite me back. Thank you. You got it.
非常感谢。谢谢大家。不，我真的很喜欢。谢谢。谢谢。请再邀请我来。谢谢。没问题。
Oh boy. Yeah. Okay. Who was that again, Tom? I turned to Jay, well, we both turned to each other. I almost started crying at the end. Yeah. I almost started crying, I swear to God,
天哪。是的。好吧。那是谁来着，汤姆？我转向杰，呃，我们俩都看向对方。到最后我差点哭出来。是的。我差点哭出来，我发誓，
when he was just in the middle. We're just talking about loss. Yeah, and, but even before that, because I had an out-of-body experience about, was like, how did my little dumb ass from Chicago get to this point? At the same moment, I was sitting there, he was telling a story,
当他正处于中间的时候。我们只是在谈论失去。是的，而且，甚至在那之前，因为我曾有过一次濒死体验，大约是，我这个来自芝加哥的笨小子是怎么走到这一步的？就在我坐在那里的同时，他在讲一个故事，
and I'm just staring at him going, I'm sitting here watching, giving my full attention to the President of the United States. And he looks you right in the eye. Right. I mean, not a lot of people get to meet him, let alone ask him questions. Because you know, when he's in crowds,
而我只是盯着他，坐在那里看着，把全部注意力都集中在美国总统身上。他直视着你的眼睛。对吧。我的意思是，没多少人能见到他，更不用说向他提问了。因为你知道，当他在人群中时，
people try to grab him and ask him something really, really fast, but he's on the move, so he can't do it. He has to get him and like, have him there. His, you know, you can tell a lot when you're, you can tell a lot when you're watching somebody on television, or you're watching them on a, you know, talk show,
人们试图拉住他，飞快地问他一些问题，但他一直在移动，所以他没法回答。他必须抓住他，把他留在那里。你知道的，当你通过电视或脱口秀节目观察某个人时，你能看出很多东西，
or you're reading an interview with them, or something like that. You can feel like you can kind of, but being across from somebody, you could, nothing, you can, you can tell everything. He really did seem like the most genuinely empathetic kind. And he truly cares. Yeah.
或者你读到对他们的采访，或者类似的东西。你会觉得你大概可以，但是坐在一个人对面，你可以，没有什么，你可以，你可以看出一切。他看起来确实是最真诚、最有同理心的人。他是真的在乎。是的。
By the way, it's such a great vibe. And here's the other thing. You know, we talk a little bit about, you know, what side you fall on politically, et cetera, et cetera. You can't blame a guy who has such a great vibe and a passion for the country. And you can hear all the mudsling you want, but when you see someone who's dedicated their life,
顺便说一句，这里的气氛太棒了。还有一件事。你知道，我们讨论了一点关于你政治上支持哪一边等等之类的话题。你不能责怪一个拥有如此棒的氛围和对国家充满热情的人。你可以听到所有你想听的攻击和诋毁，但当你看到一个将一生奉献给国家的人时，
has it made a ton of dough? Right. Went into public service at age 29, and has dedicated his life, his whole life to that, through thick and thin. How could you say, yeah. How could you say that what he's doing is anything, but absolutely in the service of this.
赚了海量的钱？对。他29岁就进入了公共服务领域，一生都在致力于此，无论顺境逆境。你怎么能说，是的。你怎么能说他所做的一切，不是绝对为了服务于这个国家呢。
And admiration. Yeah, but even just on just people skills and vibe alone, wouldn't you, no matter what party you associate yourself with, wouldn't you want someone like that to represent you? Like he just seems like the greatest guy. That's a great point. That's a great point. He's human.
还有赞赏。是的，但仅从人际交往能力和个人气质来看，无论你支持哪个政党，难道你不想让这样的人代表你吗？他看起来就像个最好的人。这真是个好点子。这真是个好点子。他很有同理心。
That's a great point. Even if you don't agree. Right. What do you want? Somebody that like, yeah, has no ulterior motive. The figurehead of the country. It's like, I'm proud of that. He just seems like a decent dude.
这是一个很好的观点。即使你不同意。对的。你想要什么？一个像，是的，没有不可告人的动机的人。这个国家的象征。这就像，我为此感到自豪。他看起来只是个正派的人。
You know, just thank you. I know. And of course, in this great person that we're talking about. Not you. Is the president. Yeah, not you. Mr. Joe.
你知道的，只是谢谢你。我知道。当然，我们谈论的这位伟大人物——不是你，是总统。对，不是你，乔先生。
Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye.
再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。
Smart. Lass. Smart. Lass. SmartLass is 100% organic and artisanly handcrafted by Rob Armjurf, Bennett Barbicoe, and Michael Grand Terry. Smart. Lass.
聪明的女孩。聪明的女孩。SmartLass 是由罗布·阿姆朱夫、贝内特·巴比科e和迈克尔·格兰德·特里百分之百有机手工制作的。聪明的女孩。
Our next episode will be out in a week wherever you listen to podcasts. Or you can listen to it right now, early on Amazon Music. Or early and add free by subscribing to Wondery Plus in Apple Podcasts or the Wondery app. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们的下一集将在四周内发布，您可以在任何收听播客的地方收听。或者您现在就可以在 Amazon Music 上提前收听。或者通过在 Apple Podcasts 或 Wondery 应用中订阅 Wondery Plus 来提前收听并免广告。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。